peu
galli
regarde c'est peut-être 100 rue n'oublie
pas que c'est pas la fois pratique
excitant économique
trois pièces selon lui remettent une
bulle de droit peut faire ton marché
allez un mariage où a notamment emmené à
l'hôtel c'est super nom virgin
tu sais bien pour moi la haute couture
et la couture c'est l'hébreu et puis
c'est pas d'endroit pour parler de ça
en tout cas qu'il faudrait que tu fasses
mon chéri parce qu'on s'habille pas à
paris comment sa vie avait il faudra t'y
faire ma chérie on aura encore moins
d'argent pour ce biais à paris qu'on en
avait un débat
non
[Musique]
prochaine fois qu on voyagera pages de
trouver une voiture qui ne gâche pas de
50 kg mais parce que nous abandonner son
art où des combats gages
figure toi qu une bielle le président
les vielles c'est comme du matin ça que
ça sert à quoi exactement à transformer
un mouvement vertical en mouvement
rotatif dubois s'est tournée tu me
raconteras ça pendant les longues
soirées d'hiver
[Musique]
le
oui
[Musique]
bon
oh
[Musique]
le grand molière une personne en face à
mayer tête avant de partir à écoute je
redécouvre paris par humour découvre
intérêts de tous les deux non et bien
moi qui ai fait mes études à paris je
peux te dire que paris n'a rien à voir
avec notre perpignan matin à paris
personne ne connaît personne
on ne sait même pas si son voisin de
palier jaune noir ou blanc aux personnes
ce qui prend pas inquiète pas les
parisiens pour moi je les caresse une
petite provinciale les insultes déjà ça
commence bien après un mois de mariage
de perdre tant provincial ce n'est plus
une insulte
celui bon tu seras la plus parisienne
des perpignanais
cette plaie cuisse
la tour eiffel regarde
embrasse moi maintenant ah oui
maintenant pas la semaine prochaine
pourquoi
ce que premièrement ça va nous porter
pâle
parce que je ne me
[Musique]
les
juncker
[Musique]
un pas vite qu'ailleurs
tel est une adorable veuve
d'officiellement bonjour
à
la barre aulas c'est tout
il
viable comme quelqu'un qui a subi
pendant un demi siècle un colonel de la
légion bon bah t'es sûr qu'on ne vote
pas pu s'installer ailleurs que je suis
celle et sans elle on serait jamais
monté à paris il neige à l'oeil qui te
rends compte le temps de me faire une
bonne clientèle on sera très bien
très très bien tu verras
[Musique]
tu crois que nous laissera m sur la
façade pour le championnat pourquoi pas
et avec seulement sur rendez vous c'est
encore mieux
[Musique]
ce fait tous ses bagages
à en croire que nous voulons en veille
j'ai pourtant année le strict minimum
paris
est ce que la part tourné à 30 millions
[Musique]
mon petit porte attestait quel droit de
te revoir
tellement vitale pas et palettes en
mariage qui le ronge la boue j'ai eu
peur du voyage puis c'était un boy
tu sais je suis difficile à rumes humain
je te présente ma femme virginie mais
venaient m'embrasser ma nouvelle petite
nièce désolé ravissant et elle a l'air
si douce entre et mes enfants entre
l'habitude un plaisir de vous avoir chez
moi j'ouvre la porte à la jeunesse à la
joie de vivre aux bonnaire à la gaîté
suivez moi mes enfants
moi je me refuse à vide dans ce musée de
la chaussure colonel mardi n'a pas raté
une seule guerre coloniale du typhon
plus m6 on aime
oui à la fois lui attends je vais peur
que vous n'appréciez pas les souvenirs
de mon cher jean charles o à propos de
souvenir je ne vous ai pas envoyer votre
cadeau de mariage
oh là là je pourvu qu'il vous plaise
c'est promis enfin home et ça fait du
bruit qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
souvenir de jean charles
[Musique]
c'est un souvenir du colonel mehdi trois
dentistes à elle j'avais pas qu'on avait
une guerre coloniale en suisse il me l'a
offert le soir de nonos et neuchâtel
comme nous avons été un couple heureux
j'ai pensé qu'il vous portrait poney
comme poussé vie oui j'adore
nous adorons il fallait pas annonça
fallait pas mais vous aimez c'est sûr
oui oui c'est facile en a pas c'est
fascinant v10 le c'est fascinant
voilà vous avez là toute notre vie aux
colonies
j'ai pensé que paul pour est installée
ici son bureau de psychanalystes annonce
à jamais c'est beaucoup trop beau non
mais non à six mois je vous dis que
c'est beaucoup trop somptueuse et puis
dangereux d'un cheveu et oui c'est vrai
ça
ses membres se sent déjà qu'ils ne
seront peut-être pas petites phrases
équilibré et met toutes ses armes ces
risques est supposé qu'il y en est un
parmi eux qu'ils soient un anti cogné
onaniste colonialiste et bien votre
salon en valais va être transformée en
champ de bataille
or ne vous inquiétez pas attentes
estelle on va entasser toutes ces
merveilles dans votre chambre
même le canon compte surtout le camion
c'est jean charles qui en avait fait une
copie y prie de 8o des boulets de ce
canon l'un s'ouvrit du port certaine
dans le saloon enfin quelqu'un entre
dans votre chambre et ce serait plus
gentils et puis comme ça le sens pour le
caresser
c'est que ma chambre n'est pas de si
grands eh bien on en passe rarement
tassera opale fait ça très bien
et puis comme ça vous aurez tout sous la
main le canon et reste voilà et puis
paul plantera sa tente ici
bah oui chacun ce soir
ce que s'il ya une chose que nous
voulons pas les mois c'est vous général
etc poisson les saumons chéri
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cherry a dû patienter
si tu veux des tirs à te faire peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à noël le cas dans la chambre de tenter
ce terrain c'est pas possible
bien joué mais quand et les polars et à
peu prend très bien je le mets quand il
y est venu en sortir à temps plein j'ai
mis des tarifs
[Musique]
ma
et ben moi
[Musique]
j'aimerais personnes pierre-henri
scrabble à la colère et le métro sans
jérémy que tous ces bidules aux anges
je ne sais pas en tout cas au ciel tu
vas voir tous vos ennemis va porter de
la maille du coeur génial la reine à
laval au centre own majesté faisable
sujet vous salue oui mais je serai plus
heureuse si mes sujets pouvait m'aider à
dessein
quand vous avez le bouchon à la rigolade
tâte estelle parlons de choses ennuyeuse
les repas le ménage cité qui coince et
qui sait que les faits oh vous savez de
de tissu polaire du coup plus à non mais
un petit peu plus loin une petite soupe
au lait c'est court il va falloir
engager quelqu'un voilà attention l
argent ah non il n'y a pas de la caisse
qui va introduire des clients tu va
soulager les colonels et wasquehal ont
passé la journée la main sur la poignée
de la porte et l'ail dans le trou de la
serrure
il n'y est pas allé de main morte avec
l'attenté stèle tu as été
qui dit risque de me remercier parce que
je te jure que j'ai pris sur moi et pas
lui dire de bazarder toutes ces horreurs
dans un marché aux puces
m'enfin c'est pas tout je suis moi
veulent encore longue
kylie minogue est chez moi au gré du
panel 115 pour vieille elle doit pas
dormir tu l'a tellement bousculés mais
tu plais bon je vais fabien sont
largement rajeunie et puis je suis
persuadé qu'elle n'est pas mécontent de
la revanche qu'elle prend sur le kernel
jean-charles d'églantine
la ville attend demain j'irai à vadim
tambour battant
petit doigt sur la couture jil tu sais
très bien comment vont organiser son
cabinet
[Musique]
pour les rendez vous importants jour
elle est infirmière modèle petit cadeau
blouse blanche
quand tu attends estelle m'enfin vous
m'écoutez tenté stahel colonel bien
fringué d'accord je prêterai des
affaires vous jouerez la femme du monde
du kit docteur absolument ravis et vous
dites oh merci docteur c'est simple vous
m'avez sauvé la vie répétez mouvoir
oh merci docteur c'est simple vous
m'avez sauvé la vie non des talents à
chaleur des tripes vous prenez les mains
du docteur voulait serrer souvent ça et
vous dites oh merci les docteurs simple
vous m'avez sauvé la vie une fois vous
avez dit ça vous sortez par l'entrée
principale et vous remontez par
l'escalier de service referme sketches
aux nouveaux patients qui attend compris
au répétera vous verrez vous amuserez
comme une folle bon c'est pas tout ça
moi je suis du pain sur la planche
toi tu t'occupes de parle de saint
laurent blanc moi je m'occupe de migrer
m
ouais retrait excusez moi je crois que
c'était l'âge dit comme ça mais c'est la
loge du concierge
j'suis le concierge kessy a pas de
service madame rien en fait si je
voulais vous dire que mon mari le
psychanalyste paul le charme et moi nous
installions chez ma tante à colonel
d'églantine et au musée de l'armée
et puis je voulais vous prévenir
marquera un peu de va-et-vient c'est
ainsi parce qu'on doit me livrer des
meubles mais dites moi vous aussi vous
habite amusé la vie d'artiste est si
difficile ici loges et gratifié je peins
en attendant la gloire et vous peignez
les pois c'est pas des poids c'est le
monde d intégrer l'ère post atomique
mais qu'est ce que vous me dites là et
le monde s'est terminée au petit pois
mais c'est pas des petits pois c'est des
molécules
et dites moi monsieur pierre et
millepied fiait pays est ce moi c'est
virgin et le charme à très heureux
madame le charme
vous êtes mariés oui mais ma femme m'a
quitté
alors depuis je parle des molécules l'i3
monsieur pierre vous devez avoir
beaucoup d'amis dans le quartier penser
à mon mari a besoin de se faire une
clientèle a d'ailleurs vous même si vous
en aviez besoin je peux y songer we do
wah propos il ya votre voisine la
vicomtesse de briouze lahure mur deux
entre les emmerdeuses qui se plaint de
ce qui aurait paraît-il un canon sur son
palier et là je l'envoie balader
j'aime m'occuper de ça oui voilà à très
bientôt monsieur pierre à très bientôt
madame lochard
je voulais vous demander comment vous
appelez la concorde au maroc merci raul
j'avais reconnu
cela dit je connais peu paris et je vous
fais confiance son prix de l'heure de
location de votre aimable personnes de
cette super voiture
il faut que cette heure soit bien que ma
ram compte sur moi vous savez ce que
vous allez faire
mais non vous allez déposer devant un
magasin de meubles modernes luxueux bien
sûr et ensuite nous aviserons
madame est rendue non mieux que ça rend
au lieu que sa montée sur le trottoir
mais tête contre la porte du magasin
madame c'est que c'est interdit madame
c'est que nous risquons nous montre
amoureusement mais non raoult nous
n'aurons pas faites moi confiance
allez-y n'ayez pas peur
[Musique]
coté à 2 lo puck
et pas pratique
m
[Musique]
monsieur
à
bonjour voilà en deux mots je dois
entièrement meublé un appartement mais
quelle heureuse idée de résider pour
vous en effet quelle publicité pour
votre magasin mon mari est un célèbre
psychanalyste et depuis deux ans il a
dit jerry lee l'avait taylor dans tous
ses déplacements
il revient à paris rappelé par une très
restreint de personnalités françaises
udine qui n'ont tant pis je peux pas
vous le dire secret d'état et il faut
absolument que l'appartement soit vite
et luxueusement meublées aujourd'hui
demain ou pas après demain ce sera sec
alors vous livrez ça et puis ça
[Musique]
et encore ça ça ça et ça vous livrez
capteurs et madame au charme et ça je
prends tout ça je prends tout à l'effet
pardon j à l'aller c'est oui j'ai dit je
prends tout à l'essai oui excusez moi
madame vous les plus fous côté essayer
quoi exactement
l'aimable bien sûr chez moi dans le
décor je me déplacerai dans les quinze
jours c'est tant mieux je les garde
sinon je l'iran eh oui mais c'est que
nous n'avons pas l'habitude de justement
prenez l'habitude oui pourquoi
l'industrie française est en faillite
bien mais par manque d'habitude
oui le manque d'audace peut-être allons
un peu d'audace
alors c'est vous c'est non si c'est
moche mais en face les écouter madame de
toute façon je vais je vais voir la
direction j'ai je pense que ce sera oui
je le pense aussi
oui votre appareil vous livre à prendre
mais bientôt madame est satisfait très
rare et wallons nous maintenons
même malade devant d'antiquaires madame
va être servi très bien
[Musique]
madame bonjour madame je jette un coup
d'oeil
il m'a semblé apercevoir quelques
petites choses intéressantes des choses
y en a mais des petites non voilà je
suis faible et on modern riesch aura
besoin de deux ou trois meubles très bon
pour rompre la monotonie
cette commode par exemple et secrétaire
de tête
la commun des boules est ce que vous
appelez un ce créateur est un cabinet
louis xiii aujourd'hui je ne vous manque
pas les prix je préfère ne pas les
connaître
ça m'a saoulé serais je prends ces deux
mondes dans ce cas vous que je vous dise
les prix n'ont plus tard c'est décidé je
prends ces deux meubles
alice et dites moi vous êtes parisienne
non pourquoi
jusqu'à pignon a alors il faut vite y
retourner là bas les brocanteurs vous
présentait une copie de fermer deux mais
certainement pas une commune bull ni un
cabinet me 13,1 ils ne savaient
peut-être pas qu'en matière de meubles
possession au titre du tour il savait
trop bien
[Musique]
non mais dis toujours que je suis un
malhonnête vous savez que vous allez
rire madame mon mari est un
psychanalyste internationalement connus
ainsi qu'un analyste alors n'hésitez pas
vous êtes crb demandé huit se pencher
sérieusement sur votre cas il le mérite
madame votre muflerie ne nous portera
pas venu vous avez raison de le dire
madame il paraît que ça porte bonheur
madame rethel - séduit cette fois un
autre antiquaires et un homme cette fois
mais un homme qui apprécient les femmes
sont possibles ce drame commence à voir
c'est pile ou face
sinon on veut bien tenter sa chance ici
[Musique]
bonjour madame bonjour réussi quelque
chose vous tente
tout est rien j'aimerais prendre à
l'essai des meubles anciens pour voir
comment ils réagissent dans mon décor
moderne à je vois je vois même très bien
pour mon compte et des meubles pour huit
ou quinze jours
entre temps vous inviter les amis de
vous voulez bouillir et vous vous
demandez les meubles en disant qu'ils
vont pas du tout chez vous mais quand je
trouve culotté et charmante
je vous prêter des copies qui sont dans
mes comble aux invités n'y verront que
du feu comme moi d'ailleurs quand je me
suis laissé avoir au début de ma
carrière
dites moi pour penser qu'on allait vous
prêter des meubles d'époque
le papa risible non sienne perpignan
mais vous n'avez pas du tout d'accent
non je n'ai perdu en apprenant l'anglais
lui faut que genia il me semble que mon
chauffeur et des ennuis livres et moins
cher monsieur ce que vous choisirez
madame le shard m'en direz tant
10 to peer la maison espoirs mon mari
sera ravie mais je serai moi même avis
surtout si votre mari n'est pas un
gentil à jean déchiré mois fin à ses
jours et je le ferai plus l'ordre est
madame ce qui est fait est fait
oui non
jean
et
du nord pas
village en indoor je vous l'avais bien
dit raul que nous n'aurions pas de
contravention
avant de le déposer chez moi raul
pouvait m'arrêter devant une agence de
placement
qu'est ce que madame appel à une agence
de placement bijoutier de la place
vendôme
non j'ai à faire du lèche car en place
vendôme à l'autre jour car je ne veux
pas dépasser l'heure prévue home avec
madame les minutes supplémentaires
seraient les minutes de plaisir
si je connaissais l'administrateur je
vous ferai engagée à la comédie
française
madame est trop bonne mais j ai déjà été
à comme quoi corps il fait comme ça
correspond à quoi peut rester à la
comédie française et toute chose mal à
tenir une lance juno hallebardes un flan
pour allumer au foot j'ai envie de
remuer au sort vous a jamais laissé pas
à moi même barrage des pensionnaires
jalousie des sociétaires à 6,6 une fois
je je ne vais crier vive le roi j'ai
crié vive lampe à ça pour faire un effet
j'ai fermé faire ça a été le dernier ont
mal équipés
cette agence de location de voiture non
engagé et sortant de la comédie
française on m'a confié la cie madame
achète une voiture particulière qu'elle
n'hésite pas à faire appel à moi je la
conduire est gracieusement au dehors de
mes heures de service pour l'amour du
dea en la scène des viols madame c
c'était beau comme l'antique et aussi
émouvant qu'un drame en cinq actes de
victor hugo sur le panier c'est pas sa
place d'avant c'est une chose me donne
des idées moi et puis elle empêche
l'accès je veux prix de remporter cette
chose là chez vous non voilà les
manières nous sommes dans cet immeuble
des locataires d'une certaine éducation
vous fera expulser vous m'entendez je
suis furieuse une série stoppée mais je
vous comprends mal à me convient à votre
place je serais tout aussi furieux
à tous le même vous me comprenez si je
m'en prends deux mois votre place avec
le physique que vous avez vous avez dû
avoir toute votre vie
je serai non seulement continuellement
furieuse oh scandalisé le serré et ghrib
je me demande même voyez vous si je me
serais pas déjà suscité depuis longtemps
ce qui va quand même des choses que dieu
ne devrait pas afficher à ses créatures
j'ai fait la connaissance de votre
voisine de l'i30 et du buzz comme ça
vous avez fait mieux connaître je vais
l'inviter à prendre le thé avec plus que
vous êtes-vous dit oh vous savez ce
qu'on dit dans ces cas là les banalités
de bonbonnes de gaz
alors puisque parmi vous êtes tous les
deux des os de julie j'espère que les
français donnent envie mais l'immeuble
que je n'ai pas fans et moi non plus
j'espère que tu n'as pas signer de
chèque
rassure toi j'ai trouvé une autre
formule est la raccompagne ans il faut
changer d'ameublement tous les quinze
jours à m'élancer deux avantages
on ne s'en lassera pas il sera toujours
dans du neuf lui donner un jeu truqué
jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma vie
[Musique]
et puis j'ai fait le show 31 janvier
dans une agence de placement et on doit
m'envoyer un domestique mal dès que
possible
c'est plus prudent
à propos où tu t'es bien débrouillé pour
naviguer dans le métro au beaucoup mieux
stage 3 buts rêve
r j'ai téléphoné à 10 pour la tour
qu'est ce que c'est que ça un
condisciple de papa politiques quels
qu'ils ont de l'argent et président
directeur général de l'union des comptes
j'espère une gamme prêter de l'argent
pour démarrer ça s'annonce bien
il nous invite à dîner vendredi prochain
chez maxim smokings et robes longues et
en russie les deux crans et aux caisses
qu'ils vendent comme moi du baume au
coeur
je crois le plus grand psychiatre dehors
peut m'aider dans ma carrière m'envoyer
des clients compris vendredi soir je
serai vraiment belle mais parle de
boutons qui mariée que ça paierait que
ces jeunes hommes la prennent pour la
robe la haute couture en ce moment
saturé petit traité grandes oies et pour
vous vous êtes gentil donc sngm
perpignan
mais quand on croit que j'arrive tout
droit des pyramides mais je le ferai
[Musique]
savoir s'il te plaît
le rail pour une hybride plug ce que
nous avons fait et pippa l'est jusqu'à
la fin de ma vie je ne veux plus jamais
entendre parler peinture
pigeât puisque ma peinture vous
intéresse je me suis permis de vous
apporter une de mes toiles déjà barry
[Musique]
prétend monsieur pierre concierge est
pas le post atomique
c'est réussi
mais qu'est ce que c'est et pas les
instants infinitésimaux de l'ère post
atomique
vous m'avez compris voilà voilà c'est
mon cadeau de crémaillère en quelque
sorte c'est trop beaucoup trop fallait
pas obligé c'est bien mu enfin moi vous
savez ça me fait plaisir alors et vous
aussi j'espère que ça à l'avancé
l'hommage est une bonne nouvelle pour
vous audoise hilali comtesse et dans le
plan elle s'est cassé une jambe en
donnant un coup de pied dans le cadeau
ou la push up faudra que j'aille vous
excuser alors vous pourrez lui
transmettre mes voeux de rétablissement
tarifs et les choix sur chypre très
chance
regardez on dirait une pointe de petits
pois extra fort devant une 2 les six
têtes de lit pharma bretonne est ce
qu'il ya une boîte de quelque chose à
manger un petit creux du jeu je peux
faire l'énergie j'ai vu dans un
réfrigérateur éviter de champagne ont
peut-être ouvrir mais si fragile résume
oublié que je l'avais acheté pour fêter
votre avis
les petits pois ça s'arrose et
volontiers je suis aps les deux autres
soirées barcelone
le chef de police vous êtes oui et alors
ils viennent de l'alliance pour quoi
faire
j'ai fait tout ce que vous voulez
commencer à tout ce que je veux je ne
veux rien vous avez demandé au nombre à
tout faire l'ong laissez moi encore un
sens fort et puissant semaine est
pourquoi pas virginie le charme de ce
personnage n'est pas plus valet de
chambre témoin que pourquoi il me paraît
très bien éléments les milliers costaud
et puis quoi un homme c'est un homme
pour les gros travaux de la maison c'est
vrai pour les fous furieux turris
d'avoir dans son bureau sanitaire
maintenant quand on me fait confiance et
je te dis que c'est la prison mais oui
si tout seul car annoncé l'accord aux
vous engage
[Musique]
tellement vous donner la clé la chambre
de bonne et huw ou redescendre et nous
cerner dans la cuisine
allez on est sympa on part tous les
mondes hit radio respecte pas
au revoir notre room avait sauvé la vie
je ne saurai jamais assez gourmand mais
c'est la moindre des choses c'est
maintenant aux marcheurs madame partez
vous vous y rendez vous non je me suis
dit que j'aurais peut-être la chance de
voir le docteur cinq minutes entre deux
rendez vous mais bon tant au nom cinq
minutes c'est juste pour le montrer une
collection une collection quoi de livres
érotiques très raffiné que je place chez
les médecins
ils en sont particulièrement friands oui
et pas moins de marina friands de ce
genre de maçonnerie comme rien bien il
suffit pas tu peux venir déjeuner quand
je pense que cette bouffe tout aspect là
du staff et inquiète puisque le service
est pour rien c'est pas grave ça lui
rohmer appétit en propre ou c'est toi
que j'ai dans frigo parce qu'ils m'ont
calmé poulet une boîte de pâté alors je
sais pas si c'est pour des clients que
tu as besoin de prendre huit amis ça
fonctionnera mois montrent qu'il faut je
t'assure au fait tu fais moi non pedro
est ce que la cantine si madame elle est
là la cousine pourrait me servir et qui
bien qu est ce que vous faites là tu as
tu été parfaite par instinct mais
c'était bon pour rien ça dépanne clients
piquante de nu
[Musique]
ouais
azimov bonjour monsieur
rencontrez vous avez rendez-vous nantua
mais le gars est en bas je vais aller
chercher ni qui êtes vous exactement
alphonse nouvelle beck directeur du
casino de landerneau wii est venu
chercher qu'ici je ne suis pas indiscret
la troupe attend la troupe de flamenco
les douze danseurs lors ce parasite
hausse mais il doit passer dans mon
casino à landerneau l'austrasie toscane
est pas mais c'est messi lagence m'a dit
que pedro son père sa mère ses quatre
soeurs et ses cinq frères étaient logés
chez vous depuis trois jours à pitre du
docteur merci merci de bien je ne suis
pas un malade
voilà c'est moi qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
les voilà
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le maillot
non
[Musique]
les minots jamais qu elle sait mieux les
cinémas
[Musique]
une troupe de femmes est reproché et 12
ils étaient 12 est l'objet dans la
chambre de bonne et nourris je comprends
maintenant pourquoi que les lapins qui
me servait pedro on n'avait jamais de
râble et je voulais j'avais des lycées
la japan cup
j'ai demandé à maman nous envoyer la
victime ont-ils qui m'a élevé à l'epa
décoratives
oui mais les solistes elle troupes tout
ça c'est de ma faute
tu me pardonnes bah oui bien sûr
mieux que ça oui ma chérie je te
pardonne
là tu es contente à l'éveil offre aux
principes
[Musique]
pas pour être un peu coopératif et
mélanie boillat faire ça pour mon merci
donc à ses toits des flammes à cause de
mes voix parce que c'est pas dans ces
femmes comme tu dois vous remercier pour
pas m'être laissé tenter par une maman
de prix tiens les citoyens mideci
[Musique]
vous plaît
didon ci a déjà fait de la couture
elles ont en fait si un bouton principal
normalement de se battre on devrait y
arriver surtout ce qui mène à tout je
suis pas tout d'être qu'une autre
voisine onatra sans une certaine
surprise qu une très jolie ampleur
dansante allège la juge l'a dit danse de
la juppette peut s'élargir grâce à un
subtil panneaux de fond qui s'appuie
sans trop s'appuyer sur pièces massives
ayant le mieux les affiner on tue mais
compte que je ne fais que ça j'ai mal
agi
la jupe s'arrondit s'évase en donnant un
mouvement d'une à thouars une sorte de
drap et qui fait la route
[Musique]
je ne vois que ça va devenir un grand
pas c'est tout ce que je vois ça puisque
c'est comme ça je montrais jaffray moi
même c'est trop
faux et jour nous disent n'importe quoi
et je suis sûr qu'ils sont de mèche avec
des gens prêt-à-porter
non je me serais pas du tout faits je
m'obstine ray et je réussirai coûte que
coûte
et bien moi je passerai chez mon copain
bertrand j'enfile le smoking et ils me
prêtent et on se retrouve sur l'axé
tâche de ne pas trop faire attendre du
point la tour parce que c'est le
banquier qui leur prêter de l'argent
oui mon chéri je prendrai un taxi et je
serai chez maximum à 9h pile et vous
suggère monsieur d'avoir dit à votre
famille 9 heures oui chère madame des
soeurs riesch qui ne comprend pas elle
avait du mal à trouver un taxi
oui peut-être
je fais comme aller téléphoner à la
maison sucre explique ma ces retards il
voulait vous m'excusez avant mais je
vous en prie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
info
[Musique]
l'attaché du voilà tout
c'est beau mais c'est du pur la fio
j'étais sûr avant qu'ils s'en prennent
au premier coup d'oeil
désolé chère madame je suis professeur
intériste
rabbit c'est beau mais c'est du pur la
cgt si vraiment ça sans koné du premier
coup d'oeil
[Musique]
pas de crier
excusez moi pour ce léger retard mais
vous avez
mais sinon oui mais si l'hôtel mais vous
voyez c'est réparé g oui mon mari
eh bien ils s'inquiétaient de votre avis
les parties route et les produits mais
le voici justement voulu offrir inquiète
pas mon service mon poursuivant c'est en
toi je suis là de tentes y aurait un
vrai sans doute très bonne sortie
[Musique]
pour moi ce sera un régime jim nous
sommes nous pas les esclaves de neuilly
n'est ce pas mesdames adieu macaronis
curit stocker et cassoulet dovi
religieux me touati
pour moi ce sera tout ce qui m'est de
plus simple et de plus léger monacale
caviar diront et omar à la parisienne
rien qui risque de rester tournoi
[Musique]
je viens vous êtes prêt parisienne aux
provinciales et
vous savez j'ai remarqué en fait ils
débuteront coup plus de parisienne en
province mais j'ai l'impression cher ami
que tu traites à la pointe de la mode
qui vous déshabillez moi avec les moyens
du bord
si j'en juge par votre d'égalité moyens
sont limités à jeunes ménages
ça va se passer comme ça vous avez dû
savoir que celle du sombre et de chalon
[Musique]
moi j'ai trouvé une petite couturière
qui a une sorte de génie et géants
lancés à la haute couture depuis
longtemps si vous voulez je vous
donnerai sonabel est à vous est beaucoup
trop aimable mais je crains que ce qui
se voit génial sur vos chaussures mois
une catastrophe
oui enfin il faut beaucoup de talent il
faut porter ce genre de choses pour moi
s'est il bien si nous dansions une de
ces petites pourraient en attendant les
ignares non merci
nb raisonnables' de lahti alors c'est 30
[Musique]
m
non non non
mais
[Musique]
et
ce qui revient avec sa danse moderne il
n'y a pas de chorégraphie on fait ce
qu'on veut mais en facebook
à
nous
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
monsieur le charme est ce que ça vous
dérangerait de nous raccompagner tout
lic
non pas du tout oui secret que nos maris
nous est utile
votre femme les a subjugué quand je
pense que mon mario rossi jorge finale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment
[Musique]
c'est toi
m
à
oui
[Musique]
oh
hors cac perd 6 ha oui merci ça tu peux
te dire merci et jeudi c'était
parfaitement merci les remercierons
jamais assez
et puis en plus tous les sols avec ses
deux chiens tu prend tous les risques
aux cullen et ben je parte avec l'un
d'eux pour monter car mourinho il aurait
été très facile
fabula que donneur femmes s'avancent à
oui j'ai eu le temps de la voir quoi
miser
oh oui il fait moins une scène de
jalousie qu'elle merlet et j'adore ça
cela dit quand tu montes sur des
branchements je tiens attendant cette
chose c'est que le père du parcours de
près de 200 mille francs pour commencer
en ami c'est à dire sans intérêt et que
le professeur le cran donc vers une
partie de sa clientèle
amen maintenant je t'écoute
et bien qu est ce que tu as à me
reprocher je t'écoute la robe
[Musique]